kidding the reason you're here right now
is because the term high value man seems
to be everywhere full disclosure I
didn't create the term guys high value
man has been with us for a long time I
have just put my own unique spin on it
and kind of popularize it and it has
kind of gone viral but here's the thing
so many people are talking about high
value this high value debt and many
times they're actually talking about me
and saying as though well Kevin said
this or Kevin said that and many people
are getting it 100 wrong so in an
attempt to make sense of all this I want
to give you guys the simple six basic
principles that I Define as being high
value now again you don't have to agree
with what I'm saying but this is what
I'm talking about when I'm saying a high
value man so your mileage may vary your
opinion is your opinion but when I'm
talking about it this is what I'm
talking about so let's get it started
first of all let's go over some basic
definitions hi great greater than normal
in quantity size or intensity value the
regard of something hell to deserve the
importance Worth or usefulness to
something and man an adult human male so
when you put all that together what do
you have an adult human male that's
greater than normal importance or
usefulness to what their group basic
economic principle states that the value
of something is what a market is willing
to pay for it the value is determined by
what the market and when we're talking
about individuals the market is other
people men or women so a high value man
is completely determined by the market
case in point you can have a vehicle a
home anything in your possession you can
hold it dear it could be supremely
important to you but when you put it on
the market the market decides and
there's an upper limit and a lower limit
it doesn't really matter if you think
the low is too low or the highest not
high enough that's what the market is
willing to pay for it and that is its
overall value that has been with us
forever so when we start talking about
that we're dealing with people it really
throws people off because it seems so
cold so calculated but like it or not
that's the way the world is so let's get
into this whole high value man thing
number number one in order to be a high
value man it starts with money again
like it or not I didn't put the six
figure thing out there it's been with us
since the mid 80s and like it or not
that's where this whole thing starts you
can't be high value and homeless so you
have to make a certain amount of money
and the line is roughly at ten thousand
dollars a month adjusted for Atlanta
dollars if you live in San Francisco L.A
New York City or the cost of living is
higher than 100 you need to adjust it so
ten thousand dollars a month gets the
starting point off for high value don't
shoot the messenger I'm just giving you
what the world gave me number two that
money needs to be made over a length of
time I.E performance and that's roughly
about five years and about the three
year mark you're kind of starting to
scratch the surface why does it need to
be five years well because guys it's a
matter of consistency and stability look
in the NFL the NBA anybody can have a
great season but having a great season
does not automatically mean you're going
to the Hall of Fame team they want to
see consistent numbers over a period of
time you know how this works just like I
do in business you can't be a one hit
wonder or have up here and down there
consistency performance over a length of
time that's why their five year mark is
so important like I said around three
years you're starting to scratch the
subs but in five years people can pretty
much count on you to say this person
understands and knows how to get it done
number three is group acceptance like it
or not guys high value man is like a
fraternity it's like a club a secret
society and high value being no other
high value men they're welcome them into
the group they know what it takes to be
there they know what it takes to get in
there and high value men group
acceptance is supremely important guys
secret societies fraternities
organizations have always been with us
and you know how this this works and
just general interaction guys that just
make their own secret society of Club
but it doesn't matter as much as
somebody says that group is important
guys this is about separation high value
men tend to huddle around other high
value men for reasons I'm going to go
into a little bit later but group
acceptance is another critical comp
another critical component of being a
high value man why is group acceptance
so important because the next part a
network you have to have a network of
other high-value men and others this is
another stumbling block for a lot of
guys for a lot of people because they
may have the money even the length of
time they may look like they fit the
group but if they don't even have any
other high value contacts or network a
group of others that person is going to
be looked at with a side eye think of it
like this if you're sitting at the table
with 10 high value men in each of these
10 men has 50 contacts that's 500
contacts and you sit at the table and
you have twice as much money as any
other man on there but you have zero
contacts what can you effectively get
done other than throw money at it these
other men can make phone calls exert
influence move things to get things done
and you can only do what you can only do
what offer money and potentially feed
off that network of contact one thing
high value men no one understand that
time is what's important and building a
network that actually works for you is
extremely important in some areas it's
called a book of business a book of
business can make you successful here
here and here your contacts your network
your network is your net worth you've
heard this before so you cannot
underestimate how important having a
network of high value men and other
people is to your status as a high value
man after the network we got to have the
visibility guys your income and your
position has to be LinkedIn level think
of it like this this person says they're
the CEO of a Fortune 500 company this
person is head of thoracic surgery at
Johns Hopkins this person is VP emerges
and acquisition at Bank of America and
then someone says hi I'm an entrepreneur
three of those four people at a glance
we can pretty much estimate who they are
what they do and their relative
importance in the overall socioeconomic
structure the fourth person more
information is needed it's not enough
visibility not enough transparency to be
a high value man it needs to be at a
glance again your your position and your
income guys you may have a lot of money
but if it's coming from sketchy areas no
one can kind of understand where it's
coming from that does not give other
high value men or even the public any
kind of real confidence that you are who
you say you are again guys it's about
the market it's what the market the
world is thinking they got to know at a
glance that you are a high value man and
the sixth part is probably my favorite
part guys a high value man is useful to
others and the group a lot of times you
hear people say I don't want to be used
I don't want to be used up no I want to
be used why because that means I'm used
high value men are in demand and useful
their presence is felt when they're
there and they're absence is built when
they're gone that is how you know you're
really a high value man how you can move
things your ability to influence things
and that is your relative usefulness in
economics it's called utils how useful
are you to the group again there's no
high value homeless neither are there
any high value loaners if you have all
these resources all this stuff but it's
all hoarded for your own selfish ends
and no one can benefit from your money
your network or anything you have how
valuable are you to the group to the
world to other people that's what this
comes down to high value men are in
demand and useful to other people as I
said
yeah I just don't think it like says
anything about women but that's are we
talking about alpha or are we talking
about high value
because we said that uh well for me an
alpha man is provision and protection
you can't be an alpha with one of those
missing and protection is as important
if not more because it signals more
survival than provision you can provide
all day every day but if you don't have
the strength or the ability to protect
the people that you care about you're a
pointless man
I think that's the important word the
people you care about because a lot of
these men like you said not everyone
that has a baby with someone might care
about the people but you should care
about your children no no no no no no no
no no sometimes mistakes happen yeah not
momentum so so okay so I think you're
looking it from a culture aspect and
Community aspect yes I actually believe
everything that you're saying but I just
know in real life men of always the top
men have always had loads of baby moms
and gone out there and they're not top
men no they are because they're not
totally disagree because it's like to me
future is not talking about the trash
Tristan Thompson
you're telling me he had more
reproductive success than anyone in all
of history you can't tell me he's not
the difference would be his women would
be submissive and loyal to him
absolutely of course and they belong to
everyone it's not a prize if everyone
can have it if I if I take if I take a
Chanel that everybody can have and it
becomes Primark it's no longer valuable
now if your woman is Primark and not
Chanel you are no longer expensive so
what you're saying if I've got five
wives yeah then I'm still Alpha I'm
still I'm still real to you they're
submissive and loyal and uh like uh
modest absolutely but if they're five
hoes you're the idiot no I'm pretty sure
Genghis Khan had some bastards he had
hundreds he had hundreds of children
telling me he protected all of them with
anybody else okay so the women would not
they would be killed I think I think
you'll reach so basically a man can go
out here now yeah and have a hundred
like like 20 baby moms yeah yeah he one
of them baby Mummers might have a kid by
another person that does not stop that
man from being the fact that he's gone
out there in stool he's Alpha like I
hear what you think you're defining
Alpha by ability to have no because
it's not just that it's the ability to
go out there and to command women to
come up and still come on man's
attention and still be strong woman can
have sex with any man no no no see the
thing about us men is yeah it's like
especially if she's a hoe so so a lot of
shoes are well
I think you're confusing Alpha and high
value yeah like well um maybe but I I
think the high value is of no use if
he's not
because what's the point of a high value
man if he can't protect no because
everybody high value management because
every high value man is an alpha so so
let's take a Kanye for example
absolutely maybe high value on this side
but he can't protect no one because he's
in like he's insane okay like to me he
loses he's not an alpha in a room full
of men
in the west men can't can't because they
can't be out Alpha no no they they
legally can't yeah like like they've
basically in the west castrated man
because it's like how are they going to
protect your children when she can leave
you and not let you see your kids
like so how yeah like that's what you
pick why no no but but see that that
minimum but you're minimizing but that's
but that's distance you're like you're
minimizing what men go through women
women can wait stop you keep
interrupting me women can put on a show
women can completely trigger me like I
have seen girls oh come on you're
telling me none of you have seen a girl
that you would you would never know what
she has done and so so a good guy an
alpha man can still get tricked that can
still happen and so and so and so and I
agree if it keeps happening yeah like
but but the problem is it only takes one
time to ruin a guy
it only takes one time to to ruin a
guy's life where she can literally take
half and take the kids like how is he
supposed to protect the how is he
supposed to protect the children when
legally she can take them and she's paid
to take them away from him and have
another man move into the house yeah he
had to move out before the law is
absolutely disgraceful but just like you
were saying when we were talking about
women choosing men that are bad you're
exact words or you can't bamboozle me
more than once people men like who like
future and he's like they've got or
hoses they're not being buzzled they
just don't care yeah so therefore then
what you're saying doesn't apply to if
you have to have the same mentality for
both men and women
because because men and women are
different so I don't have the same I
don't have I don't have the same
mentality because men and women are
different I get women are born with
value men must create their value a guy
doesn't lose his value just because he
picks the wrong woman once apart from
that men we always adapt to whatever
environment they're playing picking the
high value men in the west have adapted
to the way Society is with women reach
you have to understand the way you're
speaking is yeah is if any one of us men
speak like how you're speaking Yeah do
you know how dangerous that is for us
you can do it stay with my chest no
because you're a woman they can't
literally what do you mean no because
you're you're trying to remove basically
you're trying to save my throat to be an
alpha male yeah my woman can never leave
my house no matter what no no no no no
no no no no no no no cause you've
literally said you cannot be an alpha
from outside your home so if your woman
leaves you break it you're not an alpha
anymore that removes your Alpha so I
have to control my woman but we leaving
select wise no no no no no no see you
can't still select wisely and they still
follow yeah so you can't say that you
can't say [__] off it's fine but [__]
around we're not talking about [__]
around like it keeps us so it's hard for
me to keep replying because it keeps
moving so it makes it hard for me to get
to make my points stick but initially it
was talking about one thing what makes
basically you're saying if you pick
badly or if you you said Tom Brady no
you said Tom Brady was an alpha because
he's getting divorced from Giselle
Giselle wasn't getting because she was
out sleeping around she simply got
divorced because he said he wanted to do
another season in the NFL and she said
it was selfish I didn't say because she
was sleeping around I said she's a
liberal woman a liberal woman's gonna
have liberal events yeah yeah okay but
once again once again
so I don't think personally if I date a
supermodel I'm not talking about only
fans model yet or I don't consider
that's going to make me less of an alpha
I would think actually I'm picking yeah
in fact because they're back out logic
most high value men wouldn't be Alpha
because they date
yeah
the high value button Alpha man would be
a woman who's uh you won't know his
woman Leonardo DiCaprio had Jeff Bezos
is misses doing Madness in front of him
when she saw him like it's actually like
but Leonardo is lying he's Alpha come on
no allow it man he can be Alpha I'm not
saying he's not Alpha but I'm just
saying to you that um you're defining
Alpha differently but I'll be honest
with you we Define it you don't you
don't no no we do we do I think your
definition of alpha is very unique to
you yeah
it's Universal it's provision and
protection in human nature it's only
changed in the West in Africa and if you
take people in their survival mode
people in survival mode code men have to
provide and protect women have to
nurture in survival mode that means it's
human can I ask you a question if two
men have a fight one man's girl is a
whole and one man goes not a whole the
guy whose goal is not a hoe yeah
um he gets knocked out and the guy who's
woman is a is a 304 and she's been
outside and everyone knows her are you
gonna tell me the guy that got no tax
Alpha because he's his wife is no
another the guy that I'd say they're
both beat her uh no biggie so see Alpha
isn't that see so that's not Alpha
that's not how alpha Works see Alpha is
going to be the strongest guy he's one
of them you can agree to disagree but I
think human nature and human history and
if you take uh all tribes Across the
Universe men masculinity and Alpha is
defined by provision and protection and
femininity is divine by nurture we can
argue and we can try and out think some
biology because
I've got knocked out would actually end
up losing his woman like so this will
happen right if that was actually a
tribe but the guy that stayed with the
hoe will end up being with a woman
no he's gonna end up getting his woman
plus all the other women that's what
happened but it's only valuable if your
woman is loyal having a bunch of hoes is
not valuable no it's called a hair room
it's called having concubines you're
then looking after women that could
potentially
so so the only thing that happens no the
only thing that matters is your day one
yeah these are side things I don't know
why we can't distinguish between this
throughout life men have had hordes of
women yeah these men have had hordes of
women these women have gone and done
other things but they can't out think
biology you do know that yeah but what
I'm trying to say to you is yeah if a
man has got 20 women yeah 19 of them are
his concubines and one of them is main
day woman he is still an alpha man and
if 19 of them are cheating on him he's
they can't cheat on him because they're
not his Mane they're exciting okay but
regardless no not regardless he's got 20
women yeah let's say you've got 10 women
in your home yeah you're looking after
all of them they're in your home yeah
you're feeding all of them but this
one's sleeping with that guy this one's
sleeping with that guy that's gonna
aren't you the idiot that's paying her
bills no but listen
most high value men date supermodels no
it's like very common no you're you're
different I like like I said we can take
high value in Alpha we can agree they're
different but I would not say that all
the men that you're selecting as high
value are alpha I don't think Kanye is
an alpha I do think someone like Jay Z
is an alpha I think he's more Alpha
because his woman's on smash you think
Jace is more Alpha than Kanye absolutely
because woman is on smash you don't hear
you don't get much more Alpha by doing
what you doing wait wait wait you don't
wait wait wait but you won't send me the
whole album
yeah
forever okay
[Music]
um we're gonna talk about something else
because I'm really bored of this time